i think we very often misperceive and
misunderstand what mentors do we confuse
a mentor and a champion
um
uh
so i'll tell you a story about one of my
mentors a guy by the name of ron bruder
so
somebody said i should meet ron that we
would get along so i went and met this
guy and ron i did
typical simon fashion i did no research
before i showed up for the meeting i
didn't know who he was
i showed up and he had a folder on me
you know
but we got along really well and he was
a really good guy very well accomplished
very accomplished entrepreneur
done extremely well for himself
and a few weeks later i had a question
and this is early in my career about
something and i called him up and he
took my call he's a big powerful man and
i was amazed that he took my call
you know and a few weeks went by and i
had another question about something
that i was struggling with in my career
and i called him up and he took my call
again and then we met for lunch
and before too long a real sort of
friendship evolved and i remember us at
his house once uh one weekend and i was
getting ready to leave and i said
goodbye to him and it was the first time
i used the m word
and i put my arm around him and said you
know i'm really glad you're my mentor
and he looked at me and said something i
didn't expect
he said and i'm really glad you're mine
and that's when i realized that very
often what we think are mentors is we
view it as a
one direction relationship but he was
learning just as much from me with my
perspective or the questions that i
would ask
that i would learn from him and i and so
i believe that mentor relationships are
not mentor mentee but they're really
mentor mentor and a great mentor is
somebody who has no ability to influence
your career and this is what i say when
we confuse mentors and champions very
often we pick somebody more senior than
us
and we say will you be my mentor and you
know when a promotion comes up or
something can you put in a good word for
me that's a champion somebody who can
literally influence your career
and i believe that a great mentor is not
only outside your chain of command
sometimes they're completely outside
your industry in other words they don't
know the only thing they care about is
giving you good candid advice i believe
you cannot assign someone to be a mentor
just like you can't assign to people to
be friends right you two your friends
from now on like it's not gonna work
right it might work but it you can't
assign it
and so i i think mentor relationships
evolve like friendships just like my
friendship with wrong which is
i and i believe the definition of a
mentor is someone who always has time
for you